hey guys it's Justine and I am so
excited because today airplay 2 was
finally released this is something that
we have all been waiting I would say
patiently for but I've been quite
impatient but today it's the day and to
celebrate we're gonna do a little home
pod scavenger hunt so basically I'm
gonna be showing you guys how you can
control your home pod with your voice
you can tell Siri now specifically which
room you want music and you played in
and you can even set up the home pods as
stereo speakers so this is super
exciting because you will actually have
surround sound which is something that
Maddy come on trying to film a video
here go outside okay so let's let's just
try it out another thing that's really
cool is Siri will also be able to access
your calendar so she'll actually now be
helpful what's on my calendar for June
4th you have 7 appointments oh you're
the first three on Monday at 8:30 a.m.
check-in for keynote do you want to hear
the remaining four no no
so Syria just told me that I have to
check in for the WDC keynote Oh baby I
cannot wait so this home plot is in my
office turn the volume up to 50% okay I
changed it play the new arty song in my
office now playing couldn't be better by
RT into my office you can also move the
music to other rooms move this song to
the bathroom now playing in the back
[Music]
I know move this song to the kitchen
we're not playing she's gotta go in the
kitchen
come on let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go Manny we gotta go to the
kitchen we gotta go to the kitchen we
gotta go to the kitchen
move this song to the living room
[Music]
this pig has boots on um I forgot what I
wanted to ask you play clang Stoff
everywhere
now playing clang stuff everywhere now
it's playing everywhere
come on let's go see playing black W to
put your shoes on play clang stof
Everest in the bathroom
[Music]
I'll play the song everywhere now
playing everywhere no no wait it's a
good tune
it is that this is a play keep the songs
Airy
create a lesson here what is this
what song is this this is cap featuring
trouble which is intro hi Rach rumored
sweetly and slim Jimmy son Jimmy play
clang stop everest everywhere now
playing ever is my plan stuff everywhere
okay okay okay
I'm pretty sure you guys get the point
right
Oh
[Music]
pling playing playing playing stop
playing my music everywhere
pausing everywhere are you looking at
our beautiful Hawaii picture it's
beautiful
okay now I want to test out the surround
sound so we're gonna need to get to home
pods together and put them in the same
room the setup is pretty much super
simple
I'll show you so let's go he does
actually look like a home pod so another
thing that I'm thinking is because they
decided to release air play too before
WWDC will this mean that there is a
potential to actually release a home pod
mini maybe maybe they're getting ready
I'm high let's go set these up let's go
get two of them come on Maddy come on
home pod man oh yeah do you think I
stole somebody else's award and put it
in my house Miguel one pod and let me go
get another one okay no I think you know
I'm so hyped are you excited so we've
got our two home pods this is the one
that was in the living room and this one
is in the kitchen so now I'm gonna
change it inside of the home app to be
in the same room so it should be as
simple as clicking create stereo pair so
living room kitchen where's the Sun pod
located oh sure it is okay ah tap on
home pod is tap on a home pod above it
to identify it and swap them if needed
so they're assigned to the correct left
and right but is this my left or is it
your left so if I'm looking at them if
you're looking at them so what's
happening it's stamped with so look you
can switch it
everyone this sounds so amazing play
Artie boy remix playing Artie boy bye
Flight Facilities okay but wait this
sounds so insane
you hear that so here we have our new
grouping our stereo pair I can't believe
how good this sounds this actually
sounds way better than I expected it I
am NOT I'm my I mean I am overdramatic
sometimes featuring Hannah Louise wait
is it playing in the kitchen Jew or is
it just sound like it's in the kitchen
no wait the kitchen isn't here this is
so weird
hey Siri stop playing the way that it
lowers the volume and kind of throws the
audio it sounded like this is still in
the kitchen that's so weird
this sounds awesome okay is this is it
bad if I want to get another pod to put
stereo on my TV it's probably you might
have a problem I think I have a problem
I guess the first step is admitting that
you have a problem okay well I guess
that's the end the video because I
showed you all the things that I wanted
to show you know I guess wow I could it
sounds do you have a song a question oh
please um Shawn Mendes new album here's
the newest album by Shawn Mendes Oh
Shawn yes Shawn Mendes show you guys
this really quick I hope you guys
enjoyed it I'm so excited for WDC it is
coming up you guys have any other
thoughts or predictions on what we're
gonna see leave those in the comments
below and I will see you guys soon
oh don't forget to subscribe don't
forget to click the bell don't forget to
like the video sorry it's so you gotta
say it okay I'm done let's go I gotta go
put these home pods back now oh I need a
thumbnail okay I'll put it back thanks
okay hey wait did you stop yet you're
not recording it took us so long to get
this intro of this video I'm embarrassed
we have it all no I know let's roll some
of it how's this this is too close and
you can set up see like you can play
home
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's okay I'm sweating now you play
music in ic enough maybe okay
I know you can play music in the room
okay what a new filter still on
do you see audio on this one yes any
airplay - I really like to choose it's
like freaking like every time I go to
film so now this means what your folks
just lighten up so what we're gonna do
is what's wrong you know I agree
I'm agree I agree it's not symmetric
with the fireplace I am NOT or nothing
is it's really just that's right this is
you hate it like a little bit okay so
now I have yeah
you